um I want to you just pick up with you
on a few remarks that we've been hearing
from the new brexit secretary Dominic
Rob who's been kind of setting out his
vision if you like talking a lot about
No Deal
he didn't deny reports this morning that
the government is making plans to
stockpile food in the event of a no deal
I mean are you relieved that the
government's making these preparations
or are you worried that they're actually
even talking about the fact of no deal
at all I think no deal will be
absolutely catastrophic for this country
clearly if the government thinks there's
a risk of no deal it's right to take
emergency measures but you know we've
got to be realistic about this we will
be in a state of emergency basic
services which we take for granted might
not be available it wouldn't be possible
for example for somebody to fly to Rome
because the overflying rights over the
other countries of the European Union
are regulated by EU law we wouldn't get
medicines in this point has already been
made we'd be out of the medicines agency
and they would be difficulties bringing
food into this country because of the
number of regulatory checks that would
take place some people will be listening
to the saying this is ridiculous this it
sounds like scare mongering well I don't
think it is going hungry it's just
another way of looking at it is that it
is so serious that one would rather hope
that even if we're unable to reach any
agreement with the EU on the economic
framework we would still at the last
minute put together some side deals to
address some of these issues but you've
got to understand that the language of
some of my colleagues at Westminster is
that they actively are seeking no deal
because they are so absolutely fixated
on leaving the European Union without
any ties or obligations at all
is what they want to pursue then they
themselves will be the people who
precipitate this particular crisis and
they might say that actually you know
they would like a deal but they just
don't like the deal that's on the table
and they think that no deal would be
better than the checkers arrangement I
find it difficult to see how the No Deal
which involves this sort of national
emergency is going to be better than a
deal on offer but do bear in mind there
are two issues on No Deal one is that
the EU won't give us a deal or deal
which is very bad um we've gotta wait
and see what the Prime Minister can get
through the negotiating press
the second one is you actively want to
precipitate a No Deal which I'm afraid
some of them want to do and as I've said
on a number of occasions I'm pretty
determined to stop that from happening
how are you gonna stop that from
happening because from a an outsider it
looks as if the brick cities have had a
rather good week they're the ones who've
managed to successfully get their
amendments to Theresa maze a checkers
deal through you're the ones that she's
managed to face down and effectively
ignore it seems to me that this matter
goes outside of party the question is
will Parliament or would Parliament
assert its view in this matter I mean I
have very little doubt in my mind that
there is a very substantial majority of
members of the House of Commons who both
wish to be loyal to their own parties
but at the same time are fairly clear in
their minds that are No Deal brexit
precipitated by a small minority of MPs
would be completely unacceptable but
inevitably as you start working through
a political process I wish to be a loyal
member of my own party so I certainly
don't wish to undermine the prime
minister but bust both the message I try
to get out is that whilst I wish to help
the prime minister achieve some
satisfactory outcome to what is in fact
a growing national crisis in many ways
brexit is full of challenges and risks
even if we get a deal the one I'm very
prepared to help her do that and I see
it as my absolute duty I also have to
tease as a member of parliament towards
my electorate to ensure that we don't
end up in what could be a very bad place
and I shall have to weigh that up as the
autumn and the winter continue